- I love this.
We just had Dolly on.
I love Dolly Parton,
and you recently sang for her, right?
(audience applauds)
- Yeah.
I love, isn't Dolly the best?
Yeah, I was really honored.
- Yeah.
- Lauren Sanchez and
Jeff Bezos had me come
and get to sing for her as she was awarded
that $100 million civility grant.
It was incredible.
And I actually got to sing
- Incredible.
- "Jolene" for her there,
which made me very nervous,
but it was very fun. Yeah.
(audience claps and cheers)
- You know what?
I'll tell you what.
I've had to sing one
of her songs in front of her
and it is terrifying,
'cause you're, you know what I'm saying,
the person is there.
That's their baby.
They made it iconic.
You're like, "What am I doing?"
It is terrifying.
Even if you feel like a confident singer,
it's like, "Man, don't
screw this up." (laughs)
- I had the sweat mustache,
the sweaty boobs,
the whole nine yards.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
You guys know what I'm talking about.
It's real.
- I have the sweat trickles down the back.
So that was real
- It's ugly. Yep.
- So do you remember the
first time you met Dolly,
or maybe one of your favorite
experiences with her?
'cause you've worked with her a few times.
- Yes. I grew up on a
homestead with an outhouse,
so her, for me growing up, was like a hero
because she had a somewhat
similar lifestyle.
So, I was really excited.
I had her sing on a song of mine
called "My Father's Daughter."
She came in and sang.
She showed up like that.
That was 7:45 a.m.
(audience laughs)
She looks on point at all times.
She put me at ease.
She's like, "Now hey, I'm
so glad that I'm here,
but I need you to keep me honest
in case I don't sing good,
and in case you're too intimidated.
I brought a guy to keep me honest."
And I was like, " Alright!"
(Kelly laughs)
It was amazing.
- I love your impression.